hi we're back here at devoxx 2013 devoxx
has been a great year I think a great
addition for a lot of technologies angle
in particular and I'm here with Brian
thanks welcome Brian I'm here to talk
about testing and testing in particular
web apps JavaScript obviously not just
angular right and then you had a session
a couple days ago about karma so give us
the the introduction on Karma sure so
karma is a JavaScript unit test runner
developed by a guy voy a who also works
with me on angular and what's cool about
karma is that it kind of harnesses real
web browsers so you can quickly test
your JavaScript app right as you're
developing it so kind of the quick
feedback is key that's the right looking
yeah yeah so how soon do you run those
tests on save or yep yeah so it karma is
pretty configurable but the typical
setup that we have is you you start
karma when you start developing and it
you can specify which which files it
will watch it can even watch like coffee
script files for instance and it'll
recompile everything loaded up in
however many browsers you want to open
up and and have it hook into and then it
will quickly give you the tests so just
for some idea of how this works in
practice we have something like 2400
tests with angular and we when your
wonder you're developing an angular you
know you might touch some certain part
of the framework that has kind of a wide
impact so you want to be able to run all
these tests very quickly so on each save
karma will run all of these like 2400
tests in just a couple seconds Wow yeah
so it's it's it's all about being fast
and about getting immediate feedback so
you can immediately see kind of the
effects of your changes but you can also
integrate this into continuous
integration yep yeah exactly yes we also
run this on our continuous integration
server it has all sorts of kind of
plugins and hooks so you can get email
notifications you can
you know it does it does tap it does all
these sort of things we run it in in
like a Jenkins setup so it's it's very
versatile it's an excellent tool so you
actually this is not linked and you
mentioned coffeescript in any way to
dart 2 i'm sorry to angular you can
actually write it with dart or other
right yep that's the idea the idea is
that through a kind of a plug-in system
karma can automatically like recompile
or trans pile or it can do some small
subset of your sort of your build
process to get your web app going and
then it'll it can quickly iterate
through and do these tests and these are
mostly unit tests right do you have
anything that goes beyond that that
could look like scenarios integration
tests or anything right so at the moment
we do have a kind of a scenario runner
for angular that works with Karma but
another another Googler julie has been
developing this new tool called
protractor and protractors an angular
specific I guess scenario runner but
it's it's very cool and I think you can
kind of take a look at it and you know
perhaps in the future will extend it so
it's a bit more general but for now it's
very cool if you're developing an
angular app and you want kind of a
better end-to-end experience better end
end testing experience protractor is a
very cool project so one of the reasons
people one of the key features of
angular I suppose is the dependency
injections which makes it much more easy
to test so how do you go about testing
other languages and frameworks is it any
harder than it is to test angular code
so it really depends like you said
angular's kind of been designed from the
ground up so that way you can easily
decompose it into its parts and test
each and isolation so as long as you've
kind of done a good job separating your
concerns it's not too hard to test in
karma but kind of one of the cool things
is because karma is using real browsers
I mean you can do things you know you
can manipulate the Dom you can you know
run parts of your app just as they would
run in production and then
make those kind of checks on it so it
depends on I know that they're that
other other libraries backbone jquery
apps people have written plugins and
people have written kind of help our
libraries to make testing with karim
easier but really as long as you do a
good job architecting your app there's
no reason you can't use caramel with it
great so this is a standalone project
where does it stand in terms of versions
and then what's ahead for the project so
I don't know what they affect what the
actual version number is for it but at
the moment it's it's very stable we just
kind of have you know bug fixes at this
point I'm not sure what what voices
plans are kind of for the future of it
again it's it's got kind of this more of
a horizontal architecture so at this
point like future development is more or
less about adding plugins to you know
add more options for yourself for I
build the archos system right right but
it's not something that really you know
you need to add too much more to the
core besides you know if we can make it
faster or you know if we can make it
more stable somehow so what's a good
place to start what kind of URL can you
share with us let's see I think it's the
car my runner yeah karma karma desh
runner dot github do or something like
that just search for it on github that's
the best way to find it karma runner
great well Brian thanks that's all the
time we have for thanks for answering my
question No thank you for having me cool
shoes